[Música]
bienvenidos al debate de France 24
semana intensa y de múltiples anuncios
en torno a la guerra desatada después de
la invasión de Rusia al territorio
ucraniano comenzamos por uno de los
temas que ha tenido más resonancia y que
más ha tenido eco en la comunidad
internacional y es ese anuncio por parte
de las autoridades prorusas de cuatro
regiones del este de Ucrania en el que
informaron sobre la realización de
refrendos locales de autodeterminación
para que estas regiones sean
incorporadas a la federación de Rusia
veamos
este referente es una de las decisiones
más significativas para el don Bass
hasta ahora que hemos esperado por este
referendo para reincorporarnos a la
federación rusa y regresar a casa por
unos largos ocho años
todos nosotros hemos esperado ocho
largos años por el referendo para
unirnos a Rusia
era nuestro sueño común y nuestro futuro
común
casi todos los días recibo llamadas de
organizaciones sociales y ciudadanos
comunes para celebrar un referendo sobre
la adhesión a la federación rusa lo
antes posible teniendo todo esto en
cuenta los líderes de la región de
gerson su administración han decidido
preparar y celebrar el referéndum sobre
la incorporación de la región de gersona
la federación rusa
por supuesto este tipo de anuncios
cuenta con todo el apoyo de Moscú así lo
ha dicho el gobierno ruso desde el
kremlin del otro lado la Unión Europea
Ucrania por supuesto la otan y también
Estados Unidos han dicho que no van a
reconocer los resultados y también
abogan por mantener y garantizar la
integridad territorial de Ucrania veamos
en detalle entonces Cuáles son estas
zonas tienen en sus pantallas el mapa de
Ucrania y pueden ver las regiones que
van a realizar este tipo de referendos
entre ellas está Daniel como pueden ver
una parte de la región de doñesque está
en color gris esta parte en gris es
porque pertenece todavía a manos
ucranianas la totalidad de esta región
no va a participar en el referéndum
solamente la zona que está ocupada por
las fuerzas rusas ya desde hace algunos
años y los avances que han tenido a lo
largo de los últimos meses También
tenemos las regiones de lugansk zaporiya
Y gerson si estas regiones son
incorporadas a la federación de Rusia
Entonces esto nos va a permitir al
gobierno del presidente Putin tener
control sobre las costas del mar de
assoft también le va a permitir tener
una especie de corredor terrestre hasta
la Península de crimea vale la pena
recordar que este territorio fue anexado
a la federación de Rusia también de
manera muy controvertida en el año 2014
a través de un referendo muy parecido al
que van a realizar estas regiones además
también le quitaría a Ucrania unas de
las zonas más industrializadas y de
mayor importancia económica para ese
país del este de Europa ya vamos a
analizar entonces en unos minutos Cuál
es la veracidad de esos referendos Y qué
es lo que está detrás de esta estrategia
militar otros temas destacados de la
semana además de estos referendos
separatistas que son tal vez los temas
uno de los temas más importantes para
este programa es el anuncio del
presidente de Rusia Vladimir Putin quien
dijo que va a movilizar cerca de 300.000
reservistas que serán llevados a la
frontera con Ucrania como parte de su
militar especial La pregunta es Entonces
qué tan preparados están estos nuevos
contingentes para hacer frente a las
fuerzas militares ucranianas también el
presidente Putin volvió a sacar su carta
más certera tal vez su amenaza más cruda
contra el mundo occidental y es la
amenaza nuclear Putin dijo que no dudará
en usar las armas nucleares para
proteger el territorio ruso es una
amenaza real tenemos que prepararnos en
el mundo para una posible un posible uso
de armas nucleares O es que hay
preocupación en el kremlin por el avance
que han tenido las fuerzas ucranianas
que han ganado territorio ya lo
estábamos diciendo que eso es uno de los
temas destacados también ese avance de
las tropas ucranianas han recuperado
terreno alrededor de la ciudad de harkiv
que es la segunda ciudad de importancia
en Ucrania y también en algunas zonas en
el este del país ha sido tal El Avance
ha llegado hasta tal punto que ha
alertado a los ciudadanos rusos que
están del otro lado de la frontera por
primera vez vieron como una posibilidad
que las fuerzas armadas ucranianas
puedan entrar en el territorio ruso ya
veremos esto qué tan posible puede
llegar a ser y qué tan factible puede
ser como ustedes ven la agenda del día
es bastante larga y para analizar este
tema hemos invitado a Erika Ruiz
Sandoval ella es internacionalista
profesora visitante del centro de
investigación y docencia económica Side
ella se encuentra en la Ciudad de México
y en la ciudad de Santiago de Cali en el
sur occidente de Colombia se une esta
conversación Vladimir rubinsky él es
profesor de ciencia política y
relaciones internacionales de la
universidad icesi a nuestros
televidentes les recuerdo que también
pueden hacer parte de esta conversación
dejen las preguntas en los comentarios
que ustedes quieran sobre este tema en
las redes sociales estamos en Twitter en
Instagram y en Facebook ustedes ya lo
saben nos encuentran como arroba
france24_es@santílogo que es mi cuenta
personal la etiqueta para que dejen los
comentarios es numeral el debate f24 en
YouTube ya lo saben también pueden ver
la señal en streaming y yo aprovecho
para saludar a todas las personas que
nos están escuchando en nuestro podcast
no olviden todos los contenidos de este
programa están disponibles en diferentes
plataformas en Apple podcast en Spotify
deezer y tuning Pues muy bien comenzamos
el largo agenda de temas para el
programa de hoy comienzo entonces con
Erika en la ciudad de México para
preguntarle El Punto de partida Como me
gusta Llamar a la primera pregunta para
conocer posiciones y opiniones de los
invitados Erika un gusto tenerla en el
programa como siempre y es importante
entender y para la audiencia de América
Latina la legitimidad o no que pueden
tener estos referendos esto que soporte
tiene a nivel político a nivel
legislativo que estas regiones hayan
convocado estos referendos para
incorporarse a Rusia
gracias por la invitación me parece que
es una estrata Gema más en este juego
lanzado desde
Moscú donde se habla no de una guerra no
de una invasión sino de una operación
especial y donde ahora se trata de
utilizar un principio de los más
consagrados en la carta de Naciones
Unidas como es la autodeterminación de
los pueblos para celebrar estos
referendos sin mayor validez sin mayor
legitimidad y desde luego tratando de
hacer que sea un hecho consumado algo
que militarmente todavía no lo es
entonces me parece que que de nuevo es
una estratagema una triquiñuela más de
Moscú que desafía desde luego un orden
internacional basado en reglas y que
tiene que hacer pensar al resto de los
integrantes de la comunidad
internacional
pues qué tan dispuestos estamos a vivir
bajo ese tipo de criterio
ahora saludo a Vladimir en la Ciudad de
Cali en Colombia Vladimir Gracias por
acompañarnos hoy en el programa Punto de
partida su opinión sobre este tipo de
referendos la estrategia que pueda haber
allí detrás y también de eso le preguntó
sobre los otros temas que tengo para la
agenda la respuesta de Putin de enviar
300.000 reservistas a el frente en la
zona del este de Ucrania y el posible
uso de armas nucleares nuevamente La
amenaza nuclear en la mesa
bueno Yo estoy de acuerdo con mi colega
con Erika que estas son referéndums que
no tienen ningún validez desde el punto
de vista de derecho internacional para
que un referéndum de esta naturaleza de
esto índole tiene validez tiene que
emprender lugar tener una campaña tiene
la posibilidad de discutir las acciones
tienen que tener por lo menos la
presencia por ejemplo de las Naciones
Unidas y los observadores tiene que
pasar por todo ese proceso Pero además
ahora están hablando de un referendo en
cuatro territorios y han en dos ya no es
solamente los gangs que don Bass sino
son los territorios que están ocupados
por Rusia y donde aparentamente las
autoridades que van a organizar este
refiriendo junto con los rusos son las
autoridades de ocupación entonces
claramente eso no no tiene ninguna
legitimidad y yo creo que los resultados
de estos referéndum ya se sabe porque
los números proviene
Moscú en cuando las armas nucleares
claramente es una amenaza constante
Putin constantemente está hablando de
esta amenaza en el discurso de ayer por
ejemplo él estaban mencionando que nadie
tiene que dudar lo que él dice es muy
cierto que el no va a tener problemas en
autorizar las armas nucleares y yo creo
que uno de los impactos posibles de este
refiriendo Aunque el resultado ya
sabemos a priori va a ser que Rusia
ahora va a decir que está defendiendo su
propio territorio Y así va a decir que
bueno nosotros podemos utilizar las
armas nucleares porque
cuando atacan a Rusia Jesús los usos de
edad es posible Erika antes de entrar a
analizar estos referendos ya profundidad
Erika mencionaba este tipo de procesos
de votación ciudadana como un mecanismo
de la libre determinación de los pueblos
esto virtud a nivel internacional
regiones o países que de verdad están en
la posición de poder realizar este tipo
de de
mecanismos para garantizar su
independencia o cierta autonomía de los
estados a los que pertenecen esto a
nivel internacional no le representaría
a Rusia un peso a nivel político por
desvirtuar este mecanismo que es una
herramienta que pueden usar los pueblos
la autodeterminación
por supuesto igual que está utilizando
otros tantos principios de derecho
internacional bien Dice mi colega que
podría ahora esgrimir el argumento de
que están atacando sus propios
territorios el producto de estos
referendos totalmente ilegales y sin
fundamento para para justificar este
tipo de operación Entonces por supuesto
que políticamente esto tiene un costo La
pregunta es si ese costo político se
traduce en algo más que una condena de
algunos miembros de la comunidad
internacional recordemos que no todos
los países han sido capaces de condenar
esta invasión rusa de Ucrania en en sus
justos términos no entonces creo que que
ahí es donde nos estamos enfrentando a
los problemas
del multilateralismo en muchos sentidos
y y de la necesidad de darnos cuenta de
que esto que está pasando aquí Bueno
pues podría pasar en cualquier otra
parte del mundo si nos apegamos a un
sistema sin reglas y solamente a la ley
del más exacto y que solamente respetan
aquellos que lo quieren respetar
Vladimir esto parece me da la sensación
a mí de estar viendo un guión que vimos
en 2014 con el referendo en crimea hay
diferencias en el escenario de crimea al
escenario de estas cuatro regiones del
este de Ucrania hay diferencias entre
2014 y 2022 en la realización de estos
referendos o es simplemente que Moscú
está repitiendo la misma película y el
mundo simplemente sabiendo que el guión
es el mismo no puede prever y no puede
anticiparse y evitarlo
Bueno yo creo que la diferencia clave
entre estos dos escenarios el uno de
2014 y el otro ahora de 2022 porque
Ucrania sí está dispuesta a pelear por
suscriptores en el caso de crimea Además
yo creo que hubo una sensación que una
buena parte de los habitantes de la
Península de kremías y efectivamente
estuvieron de acuerdo de que pasan de
Ucrania a Rusia claramente no tenía
ninguna legitimidad tampoco esa
refiriendo desde el punto de vista de
derecho internacional pero yo creo que
la sensación nuevamente era que si hay
algo que apoya estos aspiraciones de los
habitantes de la Península de crimea
ahora en cuando estamos hablando de los
referendos de de ahora de estos en estos
territorios en lugares donde vas en los
territorios ocupados por Rusia en primer
lugar nosotros no tenemos la mayoría de
la población inicialmente y que estaba
habitado escritores una buena parte está
expulsada los ucranianos se
transformaron en los refugiados que
vivieron en estos territorios hay otra
parte de esos habitantes está en Rusia o
está en otros lugares ni claramente no
hay formas de saber
si realmente hay aspiraciones
y como directos a ser parte de Rusia
esos son Realmente elecciones no
elecciones Perdón votaciones que están
tomando lugar bajo un régimen de
ocupación de Rusia claro Erika desde su
punto de vista un posible rompimiento de
la integridad territorial de Ucrania que
podría representar para este conflicto
garantizaría digámoslo así no sé si sea
la palabra completa concreta y
específica para decirlo pero esto podría
ser otro punto de quiebre para prolongar
más este conflicto porque Ucrania
obviamente saldrá a defender sus
territorios
significaría este rompimiento
territorial
a ver Ucrania ha sido muy clara en que
no planea hacer concesión territorial
alguna en esta ocasión y creo que en ese
sentido También estamos en un momento
político distinto de alguna manera
cuando se invadió crimea y se anexaron
crimea la reacción internacional fue
mucho menos contundente que la de esta
vez creo que se aprendió un poco la
lección de que realmente sí van a por
todas los rusos y en ese sentido pues
hay que frenarlos lo más pronto posible
entonces creo que ahí hay un Hay un gran
apoyo del del bando Occidental diciendo
Bueno pues tenemos que apoyar a Ucrania
en la defensa de lo que es una toma
ilegítima de su territorio y el
conflicto no va a terminar porque se
hagan de estos territorios si si esto
tiene éxito y no se les para porque no
pedir el resto del territorio ucraniano
finalmente entonces me parece que hay
que condenarlo desde el primer momento y
evitar un escenario similar al de al de
crimea de Erika Pero hay críticas hay
rechazo la otan Ya dijo que no va a
reconocer esta anexión ilegal pero Hay
pocas acciones Por qué la comunidad no
reacciona
bueno primero porque creo que se han
dado cuenta de que no hubo un rechazo
contundente unánime no que era lo que
Tendría que haber ocurrido con todos los
países firmantes de la carta de Naciones
Unidas eso por un lado y por otro porque
no deja de ser una provocación de
Moscú a ver si Se involucra físicamente
la otan más allá de las declaraciones
Más allá del apoyo Más allá de de los
elementos que se han enviado por países
miembros y de la otan pero no como de la
otan per sé sino en lo individual y me
parece que ese es el juego de Putin
ahora si este conflicto se prolonga al
final lo que va a pasar es que va a
resultar infinitamente más incierto
tanto para Ucrania también para Rusia
claro eso abriría la puerta a que el
conflicto se prolongue Eternamente en el
tiempo Vladimir su opinión sobre este
tema La desintegración territorial de
Ucrania si estas regiones se incorporan
y lo que significa sería Entonces por lo
que está buscando Putin con incorporarse
estas regiones a su a la Federación
es no es fácil decir lo que está
buscando
porque cuando comenzaron la invasión en
febrero de este año estuvieron dando
unas razones estuvieron hablando de que
su objetivo es cambiar el régimen
político en Ucrania luego estuvieron
hablando sobre la defensa de la
población rusa pero ahora el ministro
elaboró por ejemplo está hablando que es
una un intento de cambiar el orden
internacional y desde esta perspectiva
lo que está buscando yo creo en realidad
Vladimir Putin es básicamente
en primer lugar no perder la guerra como
tal porque las cosas no van bien para él
ahí comienzan los síntomas
inexplicables del rechazo por la
población rusa de la guerra después de
la movilización de la declaración de la
movilización la gente sale a la calle la
gente rechaza la quiere ir a defender
algo que que supuestamente estaba
diciendo que todos los rusos tienen que
defender y por otro lado claramente es
un intento de establecer la presencia
rusa en estos territorios que los rusos
tienen Bajo su control Lo que toca ahora
ver si realmente va a entender expandir
esta presencia sobre el territorio
ucraniano o va a quedarse allá Vladimir
Erika yo no sé si es que me estoy
imaginando una especie de película aquí
de ciencia ficción a ver ustedes como
Cómo analizan esta hipótesis que qué va
a poner sobre la mesa y es si estas
regiones pueden inicialmente
incorporarse a la a la federación pero
conocemos los movimientos separatistas
que hay allí pero no sabemos el alcance
de esos movimientos y si buscan
solamente
separarse de Ucrania o están buscando la
independencia y que estos territorios
pasen a ser territorios independientes y
que sea una especie de colchón y se pare
a Ucrania de Rusia y sean los te que
están en la mitad algo como más o menos
como lo que pasó con los Asia entre
Georgia y Rusia que quedaron estas dos
repúblicas sin reconocimiento
internacional en un limbo internacional
esto puede pasar este puede ser un
escenario a futuro o estoy yo en una
película de ficción muy avanzada Erika
a ver Puede ocurrir desde luego pero
creo que en esta ocasión las intenciones
de Moscú son distintas no las
declaraciones que se han hecho implican
realmente la desaparición de Ucrania
como estado independiente Por eso creo
que
Moscú no se limitaría en caso de que
esto sea exitoso y no enfrente un gran
rechazo internacional
continuaría con la estrategia de avanzar
en territorio ucraniano sí solo Sí por
supuesto sus fuerzas le dan para eso la
pregunta inicial que se había hecho si
estos 300.000 reservistas que se han
llamado van a tener la pericia necesaria
el conocimiento necesario para
representar una amenaza mayor para las
fuerzas ucranianas ahí en el aire pero
lo cierto Es que como bien dice Vladimir
esto ha generado ya un rechazo
importante en Moscú simplemente vas a
ver la cantidad de vuelos que ayer
salieron tanto de Moscú como de San
Petersburgo sobre todo varones en edad
de ser convocados a luchar por este
territorio que para los rusos ellos no
han perdido no a estas alturas no no no
Después de tanto tiempo claro tema que
ya vamos a analizar en unos minutos
Erika pasó a preguntarle a Vladimir
usted toca un punto importante y es Ese
temor que tiene Rusia claramente el
presidente Putin de perder la guerra lo
que vemos dentro del discurso de muchos
medios occidentales Incluso le hemos
dicho aquí en Francia 24
hay una cierta desventaja por parte de
Rusia y por eso están haciendo Tomando
estas medidas muchos dicen desesperadas
de verdad Rusia está perdiendo la guerra
de verdad hay desespero por parte del
kremlin por este avance que han tenido
las fuerzas u en los últimos días
Mira yo creo que
cuando puchen comienza la invasión de
Ucrania lo que él está buscando No
necesariamente es ganar la guerra como
tal a mí su estrategia No necesariamente
tiene que ver con ganar o perder la
guerra en términos tradicionales no
estamos hablando de una guerra
tradicional para Putin es un mensaje
tanto al mundo Más allá de las fronteras
rusas como a la sociedad ruso que Rusia
se emerge como una potencia podemos
hablar de una potencia Imperial podemos
hablar de una potencia que realmente
trata de superar las limitaciones que
tiene porque no es la economía más
importante del mundo y yo creo por esta
razón el perder la guerra como tal como
está perdiendo ahora no es una opción
para Vladimir Putin el está dispuesto a
hacer todo para no quedarse con la
imagen del perdedor Porque si él queda
con la imagen de perdedor sobre todo va
a perder definitivamente el poder dentro
de Rusia y él no está dispuesto a
hacerlo dispuesto a hacer todo lo que
sea posible Vladimir incluso utilizar
armas nucleares hacer una destrucción
masiva a gran escala en Europa y llevar
al mundo a una guerra nuclear
lo que a mí personalmente me preocupa
que puchen está hablando demasiado sobre
el tema de las armas nucleares
Aparentemente él no tiene miedo de morir
en una guerra nuclear y como los
propagandistas rusas están diciendo todo
el tiempo en nuestros canales de
televisión
Rusia no necesita el mundo si en este
mundo no el hogar para Rusia o sea si
vamos a morir vamos a morir todos y es
algo que realmente es muy preocupante
como tenemos un líder de una de las
potencias es a igual como Estados Unidos
Armada con las armas nucleares que tiene
este tipo de pensamiento esto es muy
preocupante claro un escenario muy
distinto hubiera sido si Ucrania en el
momento de su independencia no hubiera
entregado a Rusia el Arsenal nuclear que
tenía ellos lo entregaron a Moscú a
cambio de garantizarle su independencia
y poder ser un país libre independiente
y democrático y hoy el escenario sin
duda alguna sería muy distinto si
Ucrania tuviera armas nucleares
Moscú Hubiera pensado dos veces hacer lo
que está haciendo en este momento Erika
sus perspectiva usted ya mencionaba los
300.000 reservistas que están llamados
esa capacidad que tiene el ejército ruso
entonces para entrenar a estos 300.000
reservistas algunos técnicos dicen que
que puede tomar hasta tres meses
poderlos entrenar pero también este
mensaje la incorporación de más soldados
a las filas el uso de las armas
nucleares y seguir con este discurso de
no Llamar guerra a este conflicto a esta
invasión seguir con ese mensaje de esto
es una operación especial y es una
movilización parcial de tropas que dice
el kremlin con estos mensajes a mí me
parece que está tratando de de provocar
a la otan y provocar a los aliados creo
que el aumentar tropas lo único que
revela Es que su estrategia inicial el
plan original que era una suerte de
Guerra Relámpago hablaban de que en 72
horas caía Ucrania pues fracasó
rotundamente y en ese sentido quemó una
carta importante Vladimir porque
acuérdense que en este escenario
internacional muchos tiene que ver con
las percepciones y la percepción era que
Rusia tenía uno de los ejércitos más
poderosos del mundo a juzgar por lo que
ha pasado en estos meses desde que
inició su invasión no es así en ese
sentido por eso vuelve a sacar el gran
fantasma de las armas nucleares ahora
Putin A lo mejor está pensando jugarse
el todo por el todo La pregunta es si
eso le permitiría primero bueno la
supervivencia desde luego pero si le va
a conseguir que se mantenga el apoyo de
su población hacia él yo pensaría que no
y del otro lado pues evidentemente sobre
todo en regímenes democráticos tomar la
decisión de utilizar armas nucleares de
la forma más limitada posible tampoco
creo que esté sobre la mesa porque las
poblaciones se opondrían radicalmente Es
cierto que se han repartido ya pastillas
de yodo en rumania en Polonia etcétera
porque están temiendo de que que
definitivamente esto se pueda producir
Pero sería un pésimo precedente para
para nuestro escenario internacional y
para lo que podemos prever todos los
estados que finalmente estamos
involucrados de una manera u otra en
esta situación hay mecanismos que pueden
evitar ese escenario a nivel
internacional a través de organismos
como Naciones Unidas la misma otan o la
Unión Europea
pues está desde luego el seguir
aumentando la presión sobre
Moscú con la esperanza de que sea la
propia población rusa la que ponga freno
a Putin yo creo que lo que se está
viendo Es que una que no hay límites
desde el exterior que lo puedan hacer y
que la medida la tendrán que tomar los
rusos mismos claro los rusos mismos y
para allá va la pregunta que le quiero
hacer a Vladimir en la Ciudad de Cali en
Colombia cómo está al interior de la
federación el ánimo entre los ciudadanos
Erika mencionaba estos vuelos llenos de
ciudadanos rusos hacia Turquía Armenia
azerbaiyán Georgia tratando de escapar
de una posible incorporación al ejército
ruso También muchas personas dejando el
país a través de la frontera con
Finlandia y manifestaciones en las
calles de las principales ciudades rusas
comienza la ciudadanía los ciudadanos
rusos a discrepar con el presidente y a
mostrarse mostrar su posición de rechazo
a esta invasión
yo creo que lo que hizo Putin con la
declaración de la movilización porque no
es solamente la declaración como tal
Sino de todas las medidas que están
asociadas con este acto y esto
básicamente tiene a los rusos con unos
ánimos muy muy bajo porque Durante los
primeros seis meses de la guerra para
muchos rusos la guerra no les tocaba
directamente la vida continúaba la gente
estaba viendo a los restaurantes estaba
haciendo pues cosas de vacaciones la
vida estaba congelado normal es
precisamente porque las autoridades
estuvieron
topando cualquier intento para hablar de
la guerra como tal estuvieron hablando
de la federación militar especial pero
ahora la guerra llegó a sus casas está
tocando Las puertas están llevando sus
padres hermanos
otros familiares y es algo que los rusos
no estuvieron esperando Entonces es un
gran problema para y no creo que
solamente con las represiones el va a
poder mitigar los impactos de lo que
está pasando ahora Vladimir entonces
usted dice que es un problema más que un
problema puede ser un punto de quiebre
para el presidente
porque yo creo que se volvió en un tren
de sí mismo él está quemando todos los
cuentos entiendo que no lo fue bien ni
siquiera en la reunión en Shanghai de la
Organización de San Carlos
porque no obtuvo todo el apoyo por lo
menos el apoyo de tal magnitud que le
pudiera
permitir sentir mejor en la arena
internacional y él cree que él está en
un callejón sin salida Entonces él está
apostando todo porque si pierde el poder
posiblemente va a terminar muy mal Él
sabe las personas que están más cercanos
a él allí en samarkanda en ese encuentro
en los bekistán el presidente de la
India le dijo a Putin que no era momento
para estar metidos en un conflicto en
una guerra de esta escala a nivel
internacional empieza uno a ver también
Erika algunos movimientos desde
diferentes sectores y desde diferentes
rincones del planeta tratando de
apostarle a la ayuda para buscarle una
solución a este conflicto y se encuentra
uno con propuestas interesantes como la
que hizo el canciller mexicano
Marcelo ebrard de ofrecer a México como
un punto de negociación como un punto
para para comenzar un acercamiento entre
Ucrania y Rusia Cómo analiza usted esta
oferta mexicana que busca el presidente
Andrés Manuel López obradora meterse en
esta en este conflicto internacional
bueno la propuesta del presidente López
Obrador ha sido muy cuestionada muy nos
ha tomado a los mexicanos por sorpresa y
desde luego a otros observadores yo no
me cansado de contestar preguntas de
medios internacionales diciendo que que
si yo entiendo que quiere decir yo yo
pensaría que no me parece que es más una
estrategia de política interna del
presidente López Obrador que un esfuerzo
real de hacer de México Quizás un
mediador en este conflicto los términos
iniciales en los que se propuso esto
eran ustedes Tuvo una tregua de cinco
años que poco sentido tiene para un
conflicto de la naturaleza y la
respuesta de un asesor del presidente
celenski del retuiteó de manera muy
clara la embajada de Ucrania en México
diciendo no tiene razón y además Esto
está haciendo está contribuyendo a la
narrativa rusa yo creo que fue un golpe
Severo a pesar de que hoy lo haya podido
presentar el canciller ebrard en Nueva
York
Vladimir también desde este lado de El
Atlántico vimos Hace unos días la
intervención del presidente de Estados
Unidos en el pleno de la Organización de
Naciones Unidas hablando de una
necesidad de realizar una reforma al
funcionamiento de las Naciones Unidas y
del Consejo de Seguridad precisamente
para evitar escenarios como el del 25 de
febrero en el que Rusia precisamente
vetó la resolución que condenaba la
invasión al territorio de Ucrania las
Naciones Unidas ha sido muy criticada
para a la hora de evitar este tipo de
conflictos o solucionar este tipo de
conflictos es momento de una reforma que
reforma necesitar el Consejo de
Seguridad y esto aquí cómo le juega en
contra o a favor a Rusia
hay varios puntos para tener en cuenta
en primer lugar Obviamente el diseño la
arquitectura del orden internacional
hasta ahora y sobre todo Las Naciones
Unidas que representan una clave de esta
arquitectura internacional esto es el
resultado de la Segunda Guerra Mundial y
reflejaba en ese entonces la
distribución del poder entre tres
grandes potencias del momento ahora
nosotros encontramos con un reto sobre
cómo reformar las Naciones Unidas no es
la pregunta que surge únicamente debido
a la guerra de Rusia en Ucrania sino es
algo que estamos discutiendo nosotros
internacionalistas pero también dentro
de las Naciones Unidas así por lo menos
25 años y el problema que yo veo así con
las propuestas de por ejemplo quitar el
derecho abierto a Rusia o hacer algo más
es que tenemos también los ejemplos de
la sociedad de las Naciones donde por
ejemplo expulsaron a la unión soviética
Alemania salió Japón
aristas salió en ese entonces se
quedaron fuera y comenzaron haciendo sus
cosas Entonces yo creo que quitar
derecho abeto a Rusia no va a solucionar
el problema como ahora por lo menos
tenemos algunos de las herramientas que
todavía nos quedan dentro del sistema de
las Naciones Unidas para poder
influenciar a esta situación que vivimos
ahora Erika su opinión su perspectiva
sobre este tema
pues está mostrando los límites del
sistema que tenemos bien dicho por
Vladimir esto viene del final de la
Segunda Guerra Mundial el mundo ha
cambiado mucho desde entonces y y la
distribución de poder también no
Entonces en ese sentido Quizás sí haya
que hacer ajustes pero el problema es
que hacer ajustes Cuando tenemos ya el
conflicto y la alteración de la paz y la
seguridad internacional es encima es
infinitamente más complicado que en otro
momento y además está esta situación
minando las otras labores que realizan
Naciones Unidas y donde esperaríamos un
liderazgo en los temas tremendamente
urgentes como cambio climático no
Entonces ahora tenemos que aparcar lo
urgente importante por lo urgentísimo
que es este conflicto porque se están
perdiendo vidas humanas están cometiendo
crímenes de guerra se está creando una
enorme incertidumbre internacional que
nos tiene a todos pues más allá de Al
filo de la butaca con las economías
sobrecalentadas y en una situación muy
complicada para el de 2022 y sobre todo
con una enorme incertidumbre a nivel
internacional en todos los campos que
usted ha mencionado Erika llegamos Ya a
los minutos finales de este programa
quiero que hagamos la conclusión lo que
puede seguir para los próximos días y
las próximas semanas en torno a este
tema la situación en Ucrania una mayor
respuesta por parte de Ucrania una
reacción por parte de Rusia o
simplemente venimos así los próximos
días como con este ritmo que hemos
venido teniendo a lo largo de las
últimas horas en el conflicto comienzo
entonces con Vladimir
yo creo que primero la movilización que
declaró Vladimir Putin Posiblemente no
va a ser únicamente parcial
hay informes que dicen que el número
real que quiere movilizar puede llegar
hasta un millón de personas Lo que pasa
que esto es un proceso largo Esto
movilización no se puede hacer en un par
de días Esto va a demorar ciertos 10
meses posiblemente hay que preparar
estas personas para que puedan luchar en
la frente pero lamentablemente todo esto
indica que puchen está dispuesto a
continuar con esta guerra durante un
tiempo largo ya no le importa ni la
economía rusa ya no le importa lo que
piensan los rusos realmente estamos
hablando de un líder que está dispuesto
a hacer muchas cosas Vladimir
rápidamente sí o no será el don vacio
Ucrania el Afganistán de Putin
puede ser puede ser Erika su conclusión
para el cierre del programa Qué va a
suceder en este conflicto Cómo va a
reaccionar Rusia que podemos esperar
yo creo que está elevando la apuesta a
Rusia con este anuncio de movilización
si recordamos precedentes históricos
Rusia no le funciona la movilización
parcial pero creo que en esta ocasión
por un lado ha pasado el suficiente
tiempo como para que las sanciones
empiecen a hacer efecto y que de verdad
todos los rusos empiezan a sentir esto
segundo al involucrar la convocatoria
300.000 rusos más implica 300.000
familias más lo cual aumenta el lado de
de la oposición al presidente Putin en
la propia Rusia y me parece que lo que
está tratando es de cambiar la tendencia
de evitar que Ucrania se venga arriba
anímicamente y que y que considere que
lo que ha ido ganando puede ir a más
pero no sé si lo va a lograr finalmente
Pues a Erika de Vladimir un gusto
analizar este tema con ustedes les
agradezco que nos hayan acompañado hoy
en el programa es todo por hoy En nombre
del equipo técnico les agradezco su
sintonía la producción el programa
estuvo a cargo de Pedro Ruiz y la
producción de invitados a cargo de Tania
Herrera Muchas gracias por estar con
nosotros sigan con France 24
[Música]